so Dante's in for him sick of it now
there's a job don't think I can do it
anymore
hazel ah I've told you I'm not doesn't
matter it's not what I want to do it's
not it's not who I am
until you know who you are
you just got to carry on with it why are
you doing something what now yes as
partners to do that now just be a sec
[Music]
selfish selfish protect my phone to see
if Veronica is all right you're on face
no I'm not on Facebook and you know what
if we need a definition of selfish or
self-centered I'm sorry but Oh me you're
right yeah I'm the one who's selfish
because it's not like I spend all of
last weekend in the garden with your
mother you said you liked knowing I was
being polite no it's on rewriting
history
you
some phat am i I didn't say that geez
why do I have to put words in my mouth
what the words like not flattering what
is that supposed to mean Jim what other
work do you last Christmas you are half
an hour late calling out calling out
calling you don't pick up the phone cord
skipping I love you say hey bring you
things about roses
[Music]
please don't find out who you are you
gonna have to just carry on love
babe do you mind if we put the phone
down for a second why I sis I'm trying
to talk to you about this job thing and
when you take the phone out it feels
like conversation over I know it's
stupid but I've got a bit of a bit
refresh our ego so when you do something
I like it sort of takes a bit of a hit
and I know it's boring the job
conversation because I've done it a
million times and you've heard it and
it's silly and I shouldn't you know I
should afternoon
[Music]
it's not silly at all I'm so sorry I
just owl Jim I haven't been focusing
really I've had such a lot on and I was
hoping no of course I know of course I
don't hate you
of course I know Haley just don't know
wanna be able to talk to you
[Music]
my friends I knew you'd say something
like yeah your friends never invite me
to think that that's how it works not
true only last Sunday you invite it to
something you're like no oh hey man
we're gonna see Ben yes I already had
something in the diary I know go so you
keep saying putting the diary putting
the diary and then I put the diamond
about Allen and you spin out well I
don't know other thing is your friends
are terrible and you know that that's
why you never at the school of life we
believe in developing emotional
intelligence to that end we've also
created a whole range of products to
support that growth find out more at the
link on the screen now